i 23 hora o povo os pessoal bem dizer
mais um vídeo de hoje vou ensinar como
fazer uma rifa finalmente vocês têm
pedido dos tempos de comentários
é este quiser ser o quarta vez que eu
vou tentar explicar por que o engasgo
bastante com ele para explicar uma coisa
fácil
não sei muito bem o que dizer mas não
vou tentar é e porque você tem pedido
bastante porque eu tenho feito grande
parte das minhas coisas usando duas
rifas para fazer parte das crônicas
esporte aqui vai fazer a parte da
existência da arma internas casa em
frente mas esta aqui por exemplo não
está aqui internamente tem isso aqui
para dar uma boa estrutura está aqui
acaba fazendo propaganda não sai para
ouvir não ficasse muito simples a e
também por fazer das partes à frente
para estabilizar a equipa da honda o
treinador essas coisas eu vou deixar o
lugar das armas na inscrição
aí falta por aqui também esta aqui é o
time que eu fiz com 33
aí também fiz algumas paradas e não tem
mais para não terem que as garras do
brincar e se nem fazer cá para lá fazer
o que está ao nosso lado
folha a4 você pode usar uma folha qual o
que é e para ajudar orientar e não em
primeiro
assim de modo que faça um quadrado de um
lado e do outro
vou tratar aqui o link pra você estiver
melhor
também aqui também as linhas assim a
direção que vocês vão ter que ir lá eu
vou sair
é esse desta maneira e acaba mais ou
menos assim ajudar
depois que com dois dedos vou começar lá
na frente para trás para frente e atrás
da frente para trás fica bastante mouse
nesta parte ficou tendência de ir lá
para frente aí fica assim mike e
encaracolado encara claro não é bem a
cara claro é que nem quanto à tendência
de enrolar até é e depois só com dois de
cada lado e olhando para a frente chegou
a mim que vocês têm que voltar atrás de
vocês não largam tudo e voltam com os
dois ao mesmo tempo fica 12 de segurar
volta atrás e volta para trás e errou
mais um curinga volta atrás
volto atrás se vocês olharem aqui pronto
já vai ficar pouco resistente
depois quando tiverem bons volantes 22
basicamente foi continuar assinando a
matéria aqui
agora vou enrolar prole vou pressionar
contra a mesa lá na frente eu quiser
voltar atrás do mam com a mão e depois
com a outra e até chegar à final
no final vocês têm que aprender modo que
isso não será um item ficar assim podia
segurar a outra mão puxado
rita aprendem que gostei daqui pra baixo
simplificar a empresa
depois é só um milagre me segurando
assim na fita e já está na cabeça deles
tentou aterrissar conjunto
a catedral é tão pronto três ainda têm
que armazenar instante